il aurait pu marquer sur son affiche de
campagne 10 10 aux le retour car après
avoir quitté la politique en 2008 au
terme de plus de 40 ans de vie
municipale
revoici l'ancien premier adjoint de
château chinon dans la course à
l'élection
les militants ps le colon désigné pour
incarner le changement socialiste contre
le maire sortant lui aussi socialiste
je me sens en forme donc j'ai décidé de
repartir parce que je crois que lui à
des choses un peu différentes affaires
en ville ça donne enfin la possibilité
aux jo de sotchi non d'avoir le choix et
de ne pas seulement avoir une liste a en
face de soi est bien là les émissions de
château chinon diront on change on
trouve pas on prend le maire sortant où
on prend du new soul funky dit doussot
en lice contre un maire sortant du même
camp difficile à comprendre
officiellement la raison se trouve dans
les statuts du ps qui impose aux maires
sortants socialistes de demander
l'investiture du parti pour être
candidat or l'actuel maire ne l'a pas
fait et ils en payent le prix
il fait pas présenté contre moi la
section c'est son problème
donc les dissidents mais bon c'est tout
les électeurs trancheront le maire
sortant dissident le voici en vit mal
coiffe dissidents mais bizarrement pas
exclu du parti socialiste henri
malcoiffe surpris d'être contestée par
son propre camp alors qu'il est persuadé
d'afficher un bon bilan
pendant tout le déroulement de mon
mandat je n'ai eu que des félicitations
de la section du parti socialiste à
château chinon
j'en conclus que certains au singulier
ou au pluriel
on pensait autrement tardivement à
quelques mois des nouvelles municipales
et je le répète c'est un fait unique et
bien dommageable puisqu'il s'agit de
deux candidats socialistes
henri malcoiffe et guides ou sow se
connaissent bien pour avoir travaillé
ensemble au conseil municipal en 2001
malcoiffe saisi l'opportunité de devenir
conseiller général après que do so et
décliné l'offre en 2008 auréolé de son
mandat départemental henri malcoiffe est
choisi pour succéder au maire de
l'époque un mandat que guy doussot alors
premier adjoint aurait pu légitimement
convoité officiellement il s'en défend
et quitte la vie politique en 2008 pour
revenir donc cette année
affrontez henri malcoiffe dans un duel
fratricide ps contre ps il y aura
sûrement une même si la campagne n'est
pas très violente
il y aura sûrement des rancoeurs et les
rancunes qui feront que parti du néo
socialistes ceux d achraf est persuadé
élections municipales 2014 particulière
à château chinon combat dans la famille
socialiste a régné sans opposition
depuis des décennies dans la capitale du
morvan le ps a fini par créer cette
opposition au sein même de sa majorité